zum zehnten Mal findet die sogenannte
edelweissrate am Truppenübungsplatz
martinerlied zum in Tirol statt wir sind
kurz vorm Stadt der zehnten Edelweiss
red da inoffiziellen Weltmeisterschaft
der Gebirgsgruppen sowie wird es nennen
und mein größter Wunsch ist das alles
sicher ins Ziel kommen und wünsche allen
Mannschaften alles Gute 22
gebirgskampftruppen aus neuen Nationen
messen sich dabei unter anderem in den
Disziplinen scharf schießen
hier hat sich herausgestellt dass die
Mannschaft und 26 durch hervorragende
Schießleistung gut Organisation
Gelände
[Musik]
hüteten Suche und Bergung von
verunfalten
[Musik]
über zwei Tage zeigen insgesamt 176
Soldatinnen und Soldaten ihre
Fähigkeiten dabei legen sie rund 40 km
zurück und überwinden dabei 4000
Höhenmeter
überraschend auf Platz 3 landet heuer
eine von drei teilnehmenden Mannschaften
aus China Team China 3
platz 2 geht an Österreich an das
Jägerbataillon 26 aus Spital an der Drau
sie müssen sich nur von einem Team aus
Deutschland geschlagen geben Team
Deutschland eins vom gebirgsliga 233 aus
dem bayerischen Mittenwald 2023
[Musik]